alors que le pétrole de l'erika continue
de souiller les plages de vendée et de
loire-atlantique on redoute une deuxième
marée noire des pêcheurs ont constaté
des remontées de fioul près de l'épave
les images filmées par leurs beaux
habits sub montre que la partie arrière
du pétrolier ne présente pas de fissure
comme on le redoutait
mais le problème est que ce robot n'a
pas pu inspecter la totalité de la coque
jacques devaux gabriel camilla voilà ce
que l'habit subles robots sous-marins a
pu voir de l'épave de l'erika lors de
ses deux premières plongées une dizaine
d'heures d'investigation sur les 2/3 de
l'épave
avant que le robot de ce blog mais les
experts sont formels la partie inspecté
de l'erika ne fuit pas on n'a rien vu
comme fuite
on n'a pas eu de suite alors on nous dit
les marins pêcheurs disent il ya des
irisations surface d'un peu d'irisation
surface mais j'appelle pas ça une fille
c'est sûrement pas en tout cas du
chargement ça puisque c'est chargement
vous avez vu comment sait on l'a ses
vues sur les plages
ça n'a pas du tout le cas donc le
maintenant qu'on se voie il pourra
analyser le produit mais tout le monde
n'était retraite pas les choses tout à
fait de la même façon jean pierre salaun
président du comité local des pêches de
concarneau était à bord de la bei
supporter pour lui les irisations
visinand surface laisse supposer des
fuites
en surface on voit simplement de la
pollution mais minime mais fort probable
que certaines parties de la du droit la
déchirure qui est des fissures et que le
pétrole au monde mais c'est à granby je
n'ai pas à gros bouillons on voit
comment du sax alto qu'en surface tache
d'huile
loin de rassurer la mission non achevé
de l'abysse hub laisse encore beaucoup
de questions sans réponse les experts
réclament du temps et des analyses plus
poussées
la population elle voudrait être
rassurés tout de suite